Kelly Clarkson is doing great after her
divorce from Brandon Blackstock but
today she seemingly took aim at him and
his dad switching up the lyrics to This
hit from singer Gail
[Music]
Kelly was forced to pay her ex more than
1.3 million in their divorce Kelly and
Brandon's dad her former manager are
also suing each other over 6.8 million
dollars he says the singer owes him
divorce is a really
thing meanwhile newlywed Ben Affleck
keeps defending those meme-worthy looks
listen I have a very unhappy looking
resting face this is me content
this is
how God made me but was Jimmy Kimmel the
one frowning at Ben's last star packed
Christmas party you and Jennifer greeted
us at the door and then Jay Leno and his
wife Mavis walk in and they come up and
they were talking and it's a little bit
uncomfortable do you remember what you
said you have some kind of a death blood
Feud yeah don't you guys have like a
feud or something and
and we stood there in shock and then you
left yeah the Jimmy and J Feud goes back
to The Tonight Show shake-up when Kimmel
said he favored David Letterman to take
over for Johnny Carson both have since
made peace and after Jay's two accidents
in six months he has a new ear and a new
face when you get burned in a fire
ears are like paper it just goes up they
got clothes lined on my motorcycle no it
cut my face again so I called my face
guy I go listen you you know the face
you gave me that in the face I gotta get
her fix again
foreign